[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER 1: At first glance,
Google Cloud Platform is huge.
There are so many tools,
services, and APIs
that sometimes it can be
difficult to know how it all
fits together.
SPEAKER 2: Especially if you
have existing applications
where what you use and
what GCP offers don't
seem to match up directly.
SPEAKER 1: If you've
been intrigued
by the prospect of
migrating to GCP--
SPEAKER 2: --but haven't known
where to start, don't worry.
SPEAKER 1: We are here to help.
SPEAKER 2: Let's take a look at
a couple of application types
and see how GCP lines up.
We'll start simple
with static websites.
No fancy service stuff here.
Just some raw HTML
and JavaScript
files for client
side processing.
For this example,
Google Cloud Storage
is the perfect place to start.
GCS offers global object
storage and fetching via URL,
so content can be
fetched directly
without having to
invoke any server code.
Uploads are available
almost immediately,
replicated and backed up
worldwide on Google's network
and infrastructure.
With partnerships with
CDNs around the world,
GCS can also reduce
the cost of and speed
to access your content.
And the best part?
You can create a
domain that points
right to your GCS
buckets, so to users it
looks like a regular website.
They don't need to
worry themselves
about the whole infinitely
scalable CDN thing.
So far so good.
SPEAKER 1: But
also pretty simple.
Next, let's look at something
a little bit more complex,
but still very common--
virtual private servers.
These are VMs running
somewhere in the cloud.
You might be running a
game server or a chat bot
or anything else that needs
a dedicated machine and root
access.
Google Compute Engine can
do the same thing for you,
but comes with a lot
more bells and whistles.
GCE is a full infrastructure
as a service offering,
including a set of
Linux and Window images
and the ability to configure
your VMs with the exact CPU
and RAM specifications
that you need.
It's also got a lot
of other handy stuff
that you might not
find elsewhere,
like live migration,
multiple region
support, local SSDs, instant
snapshots, and preemptible VMs.
Not to mention
production level things
like auto scaling, health check
systems, and full integration
into Stackdriver--
which provides
tracing, error handling, and
monitoring on your behalf.
So if you're running
a private server
but don't want to deal with
all the overhead of managing
a private server, GCE
is a great option.
But in reality,
there's a good chance
that you have an application
which is a mix of the two.
You serve some static
content but also
have server side compute needs.
In that case, doing all the
heavy lifting of managing
dedicated VMs-- and
paying for them--
might be overkill.
SPEAKER 2: Which is exactly
what the platform-as-a-service
offerings are for.
App Engine Standard lets
you serve static content
and also provides a server
side compute to interact with.
We handle all the deployment,
migration, regions,
and scaling, and
you get to focus
on getting your app to users.
GAE Standard has a
flexible billing model
and allows your app to scale
down to zero instances.
So you don't pay if
no one's using it.
Plus it has built-in access
to other GCP services
like Datastore, Cloud SQL,
Memcache, Bquery, Auth
and more.
The trade-off for
all these benefits
is that App Engine Standard
comes with a few restrictions.
There's a fixed set
of supported languages
and you don't get access to
the disk of the instance.
And you definitely
don't have root access.
But if you are just
deploying a client server
system with minimal
headache, that's
an easy trade-off to make.
If you do need more
control but still want
all the managed
goodness, App Engine Flex
is worth investigating.
Flex gives you all the same
management, auto scaling,
and bandwidth
splitting as Standard,
but also lets you run
with full root privileges
with any language or
container you want.
The trade-off here
is that Flex doesn't
allow you to scale to zero
and has a different pricing
structure.
So you'll definitely want
to make sure to check out
the pricing calculator.
SPEAKER 1: Finally, let's
talk about hybrid clouds.
If you're a company with a
lot of on-premise servers,
chances are you're not too keen
to buy new racks every month
to handle spikes in workloads.
Instead, GCP offers a
reliable VPN service
that allows on
demand GCP instances
to connect securely to
your on-premise systems.
That means that
you can seamlessly
spin up new instances
in Google's cloud
to handle workload
spikes and spin them down
when they aren't needed--
which is way better than buying
them yourself and having them
sit around idle when
they're not being used.
So if you want more recaps
on great Next content,
make sure to check out
the rest of our playlist.
And don't forget
the next world tour,
coming soon to a city near you.